bonjour marges dans le cognac vous avez
notamment attaqué avec succès l'arrêté
préfectoral du bas-rhin rendre
obligatoire le masque jean castex
auditionné une seconde fois depuis le
début de la crise la première c'était
avant qu'il soit nommé premier ministre
qu'est-ce qui pourrait ressortir de
cette audition au vu de la gestion de la
pandémie
je crois qu'il faut que le premier
ministre s'explique effectivement sur la
façon dont ce déconfinement été menée et
qui manifestement n'est pas un succès
puisque il avait été indiqué que tout
avait été fait pour que nous ne
parvenions pas deuxième confinement or
c'est exactement malheureusement ce qui
s'est produit
on a l'impression en particulier que les
mesures d'ordre purement sanitaire c'est
à dire au niveau des hôpitaux n'ont pas
été prises correctement ou y attend et
les deux tests n'ont pas été mené à
temps et en nombre
donc vous pointer du doigt des décisions
mal adapté vous êtes inquiet en ce qui
concerne les libertés fondamentales
concrètement qu'est ce que vous
reprochez à jean castex
mais on a l'impression que monsieur
castex d'ailleurs comme son prédécesseur
n'a qu'une seule réponse à la crise
sanitaire c'est la réponse purement
administrative et répressive c'est à
dire que le confinement et des amendes
or ce n'est pas ça la réponse on le voit
bien dans d'autres pays qui ont adopté
des méthodes totalement différente et
beaucoup plus efficace comme l'allemagne
par exemple qui mène des campagnes de
tests massive et qui isole les seuls
patients qui sont infectés c'est ça
qu'il faut mener en france c'est
d'ailleurs une expérience est
actuellement prévue en région rhône
alpes auvergne c'est monsieur wauquiez
qui prévoit sa du 16 au 23 décembre une
campagne de tests massive dans ce
département qui le plus infecté pour
précisément m isolement uniquement les
personnes qui sont infectées et non pas
compiler l'ensemble de la population et
mettre à genoux toute une économie au
niveau local c'est à dire vous avez
réussi à suspendre le masque obligatoire
on atteint quand on arrêté préfectoral
du bas rhin quels sont les futures
actions de la sorte que vous comptez
entreprendre
alors pour l'instant à mon niveau il n'y
a rien de prévu il ya d'autres actions
en france qui sont prévues notamment
l'ue a mis h l'union des métiers de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration qui
prévoit un recours devant le conseil
d'état contre les mesures interdisant la
rumeur tirs des restaurants puisque nous
avons appris hier
mais ce ne sont que des rumeurs pour
l'instant que les restaurants ne
rouvriraient probablement pas avant le
mois de janvier voire même le mois de
février ce qui n'est absolument pas
possible surtout que les restaurateurs
ont pris véritablement l'ensemble des
mesures sanitaires possibles et
imaginables pour empêcher toute
contamination au sein de l'établissement
un journal allemand die zeit bien sa
correspondante à annonce a dénoncé ces
derniers jours la politique sanitaire de
la france est beau quand même je cite un
absurdistan comment est-ce que vous
qualifieriez vous qualifier la gestion
de crise sanitaire par par jean castex
et emmanuel macron c'est trop répressif
c'est ça si beaucoup trop répressif et
c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs cet article
du journal die zeit qui pointe les
incohérences de cette politique qui
consiste à s'établir à soi même des
attestations à ce qui n'a aucun sens qui
fait rire à l'étranger puisque nous
sommes quasiment avec la grèce le seul
pays qui a adopté cette technique
ce n'est pas comme ça que l'on fait pour
maintenir la santé dans ce pays
ce qu'il faut c'est la distanciation
physique et du co mensuel où ça se
pratique beaucoup et les tests et bien
sûr des mesures sanitaires
on a l'impression que rien n'a été pris
comme mesure au niveau des hôpitaux
puisque nous avons toujours le même
nombre de l'île réanimation qu'au mois
de mars
alors qu'on aurait dû profiter de cette
période de l'été pour augmenter le
nombre de rugby de réalisation et les
effectifs en personnel ce qui
malheureusement n'est absolument pas le
cas
or la politique française ne se base que
sur un seul critère le nombre de lits
disponibles en réanimation qui est
l'alpha et l'oméga du fait de savoir si
on confie nous pas un pays laissé on
bloque tout un pays or ça c'est pas
possible
mais concrètement vous si vous êtes à la
place du
du premier ministre si vous êtes
auditionné tout à l'heure qu'est ce que
vous vous dites et qu'est ce que vous
proposez
plus concrètement par les plus loin dans
les propositions
il faut mener une campagne de tests
massives dans tout le pays pour isoler
les personnes malades et ses réponses
possibles on a joke quand il y avait des
tests cet été il y avait là files
d'attentes devant les laboratoires
c'était compliqué à mettre en place mais
encore une fois parce que les choses ne
sont pas suffisamment organisés et si
tous les moyens avaient été mis dès le
départ pour tester comme c'était le cas
par exemple en allemagne nous n'aurions
pas ce genre de difficultés j'allais
dire purement organisationnel problèmes
de bureaucratie administrative également
qu'il faut à adapter et améliorer très
grandement puisque je vous rappelle que
pendant la première crise sanitaire les
laboratoires par exemple vétérinaire
s'était proposé pour faire des tests et
ça a été refusé par l'administration
française on ne sait pas pourquoi on ne
sait toujours pas pourquoi d'ailleurs on
peut d'ailleurs
suivra une interview consacrée à ça dans
la grenade carburant sur sur rt france
un vétérinaire qui s'était proposé pour
pour apporter son aide à l'état merci
marc agents de caubiac d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de strasbourg vous
avez notamment attaqué avec succès l
arrêté préfectoral du parrain rendant le
masque obligatoire